[Music]  i can't  he acts like it's still in there and i  don't know how to go  get one  paul central start me uh first  responders to come to car wash i've got  a young child choking  is it out of your throat baby  is it still in your throat  yeah okay okay gotta get it out buddy  huh  what's he having what did he take it was  a sucker but i there was oh no a quarter  a quarter babe  is that it  can you breathe out  can you breathe now is that all you put  in there  charles central were you clear no  is it what else did you put in there  yeah  huh  okay i've just got a  trying to do heimlich on him i got a  quarter to come out of his mouth um his  face is still pretty blue he's he is  crying now though but go ahead and come  check him out  i want them